this is the third in a series of videos
about answering the document-based
question or dbq on the ap us history
exam
in the last video we started taking a
look at and analyzing some of the
primary documents provided for this exam
so the first one was a folk saying about
how the boll weevil and sharecropping
had taken away african-americans crops
and homes in the south the second was a
letter from a black man living in new
orleans
asking the black newspaper the chicago
defender to help in finding him a house
and a job in chicago the third was an
article in an industrial journal
counseling white factory owners in the
north to segregate black workers from
white workers
and the fourth was an article in a white
owned newspaper
talking about race riots in chicago and
how african-americans were better off in
the south because they felt that lynch
law was better than being killed in a
race riot so there are three more
documents that we'll go through pretty
quickly and then we can get started on
writing a thesis statement
okay this is a song
by an african-american singer
named lizzy miles and the song is called
cotton belt blues from 1923.
now i am not going to attempt to sing
this because you do not want to hear
that but let's get a gist of what it's
about
look at me look at me and you see a gal
with a heart bogged down with woe
because i'm all alone far from my
southern home
dixie dan that's the man took me from
the land of cotton to that cold
cold-minded north
threw me down hit the town and i've
never seen him henceforth
just because i trusted i'm broke and
disgusted i got the cotton belt blues
well it definitely seems like she has
experienced the kind of con man behavior
that the man in document two was worried
about so
she's saying that she was fooled into
coming up north
for a man who has now left her alone
and she misses her home in the south
but you could also think about the fact
that she herself
if we've got the lyrics to this song and
this recording probably did pretty well
so this is more maybe of an expression
of popular culture and less of a
particular story about this person
lizzie miles
so we could talk about maybe the
influence of jazz
the fact that african americans came to
the north and
influenced popular culture
all right we're getting down to the end
of these let's look at document six all
right this document is from an
african-american journalist named george
schuyler who's writing in a magazine
called the messenger which was a
political and literary magazine for
african americans so he's writing for a
sympathetic audience this is in august
of 1925.
skyler says
it is generally thought by both negroes
and whites that negroes are the chief
strike breakers in the united states
this is far from the truth
the negro workers part in strikes has
been dramatized by virtue of the
striking contrast of race which
invariably provoked race riots
but the fact is that there are many more
scabs among the white than black workers
partially because there are numerous
industries in which negroes are not
permitted to work
which too are by no means 100 organized
out of 20 or more millions of workers in
the united states less than 5 million
are organized note the potential for
scabs
so one thing you definitely have to know
here is what the word scab means
so scab i think you can kind of tell by
the context means strike breaker so if a
union goes on strike a factory owner
might hire scabs or replacement workers
to try to break the strike so skyler is
saying that there is a perception
that black workers are often used to
break strikes
or that when a white labor union would
go on strike the factory owner might
then hire black workers
who of course are going to have
difficulty finding jobs in a segregated
economy and therefore they don't have to
pay the white workers more
and schuyler says that this is not true
it's actually just that african
americans are so frequently barred from
industries that
they can't be represented in strikes
because they're not represented in
unions or the places that employ
unionized workers okay last one this one
is a map and i'm just going to put it
right here in front of everything
because it's pretty large and if we made
it any smaller it'd be really hard to
see so when you're looking at maps like
this the first thing you want to do is
read the title because that way you know
what this map is actually trying to show
you and you're not just making
assumptions about what it could be
trying to show you so this map is about
the distribution of the african-american
population in chicago in 1930
and what you can see here are that the
sections that are not shaded at all or
shaded white are less than one percent
african-american population
the light gray is one to ten percent the
medium gray is ten to fifty percent and
then this dark gray is more than fifty
percent african american and what you
can see here is that it looks like there
is a very definite african-american
neighborhood on the south side of
chicago
which i think goes to show that there's
some real segregation
happening in chicago
and you can see here at the bottom it
tells you
how many african americans were living
in chicago over the
1910-1930 period and even though the
share of the population
more than triples in that time period
everyone is
set in this one small area
so i think that goes to show that even
if you were a southerner who moved to
chicago looking for a better life as an
african-american you might still be
subject to this system of segregation
that would only allow you to live in one
neighborhood
but there might also be a positive flip
side to that which would be that this
was a thriving black community if you
were a southerner who had lived in a
relatively rural place you may not have
been able to spend that much time with
other african americans as a young
person so that's a possible positive
interpretation but we'll keep that on
the table just in case it might help us
with part of our argument
all right now we've read all of the
documents and as we get started on our
thesis statement i think one of the most
useful things you can do is just take a
moment and brainstorm some of the themes
that have arisen in these documents
so what themes do we see here
well i think that there's definitely a
theme about
labor in general
not being able to
do well under a sharecropping system of
labor
and looking for a good job
and several things about factory work
whether
factories should be segregated or
whether african americans play a part in
the labor movement in general or if they
work against unions by being scabs
i think there's definitely a
theme of segregation or living patterns
we saw that in the map and we also saw
that in some of the
documents about
segregated workplaces
and there might also be just kind of a
cultural theme here about the
differences between life in the north
and in the south
we see that when our newspaper letter
writer says that he's worried about
being hoodwinked
and we see that when
our jazz singer talks about how she was
fooled and left behind
we might even see that with our
perceptions of black neighborhood life
that african americans may have gone
from a system of living very separately
in the south to living in a very dense
urban cultural area where they may have
met many different african americans
from all different parts of the country
i think another useful thing for us to
do is to think about some of the major
historical events going on at the time
period that we could connect to these
documents so i think a big one that
comes to mind is the great migration
which we
mentioned before which was a period
in the early 20th century when many
southern african americans pretty much
had had it with life in the south was a
combination of jim crow segregation
being legalized and also sharply
declining economic opportunities that
led thousands of african americans to
pack up and head for northern cities
now one of the reasons that they could
do this is because
world war one was creating many new
factory jobs just the way that world war
ii would do later on and so there were
many new opportunities in the north to
draw african americans away to new and
even better paying jobs what else
happened in this time period well there
was the supreme court ruling plessy
versus ferguson
which legalized segregation in 1896
which said that separate but equal
accommodations were constitutional the
1910s and 1920s were times of increasing
modernity but also a time of
cultural and racial backlash as many new
immigrants streamed into the cities
along with african americans from the
south so there was also a resurgence in
the ku klux klan at this time period
which president woodrow wilson even kind
of tacitly approved of by watching the
film birth of a nation in the white
house
and we might even talk about the chicago
race riot of 1919
which is the race riot
mentioned in document four
when and you might even mention the
chicago race riot of 1919 it's one of
the
deadliest race riots in american history
and this is the race riot that's
mentioned in document 4 kind of
gloatingly
all right so we've identified these
three themes that we might discuss in
our essay now the essay itself is about
changes and continuities so for each of
these three things was there change over
this time period or was there continuity
well in labor you could say there's
maybe a change in type of labor
but maybe
many of the same problems of race around
labor
all right what about segregation well i
think there's both segregation in the
north and in the south
but again it's kind of a difference of
type and degree so segregation still
exists
in the north
but now it's taken on this urban form
where there are majority black
neighborhoods and then other
neighborhoods where there are no
african-americans at all
so a different type
all right what about cultural changes
we could see that in some cases african
americans who moved north
missed
their old society
but then again
they certainly had many problems when
they were in the south same songs about
how the boll weevil and sharecropping
had caused feelings of dislocation and
poverty
so i think if there is a thesis
statement to be gotten out of this it's
that moving from the south to the north
african americans in the period from
1910 to 1930
experienced pretty much the same
problems but they took different forms
in the next video i'll talk about how we
can turn that into a really beautiful
and robust thesis statement and then
we'll go through the process of
outlining this essay